el ph que se mide en el punto de
equivalencia de la titulación es de 2.54
cuál de los siguientes indicadores será
la mejor opción para determinar el punto
final de la titulación justifica tu
respuesta bueno recordemos que el punto
final de la titulación es cuando el
indicador cambia de color y como esa es
nuestra señal que es una señal visual
porque decimos mira ya llegamos al punto
de equivalencia bueno queremos que el pk
a de nuestro indicador sea lo más
cercano al ph en el punto de
equivalencia y como el ph en el punto de
equivalencia es 2.54 entonces cuál de
estos indicadores se acerca más a ese p
h bueno aquí podemos ver que es el azul
de timor entonces es cogeríamos azul de
timón
azul de timón porque es su pk a su pk
es el más cercano más cercano al ph
en el punto de equivalencia
punto de equivalencia
ahí está listo